what is the hottest Asian accent it's
the hottest one this is how we're going
to settle it dialogue from the notebook
in Asian accents oh
picky about what everybody wants
it stop it thinking about what I want
are your parents what what do you
wanting
what the do you want from me
can you do a Vietnamese one Vietnamese
is not sexy stop saying that bro do you
have a cigarette or of course
stop thinking about what everybody wants
stop thinking about what I want what
your parents want
what do you want
no matter what the your parents want man
that's it you have a food Change My Mind
that's the Vietnamese because Koreans
are always whining and but the
Vietnamese is like I already know
you got me bro